for the first time in close to a year
visitors and locals can enjoy much of
las vegas without a mass thank you for
joining us on 8 news now at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez many stores
and restaurants around town will have
some different rules though but
in a lot of casinos face coverings are
not required for anyone fully vaccinated
that comes two weeks after that last
shot here is a list of some of the
places allowing mass to come off
all mgm properties cosmopolitan caesars
entertainment and circa downtown
many properties also allowing full 100
capacity on the casino floor
now on the flip side the clark county
school district announced today that at
least for right now
it will continue to make mass mandatory
for students and staff
orco mana joining us now live from ccfd
headquarters
with how the community is reacting
tonight orco
well brian and denise ccsd says out of
an abundance of caution
students and staff at all schools and
work locations
are still required to wear masks
teachers and parents we spoke to
say that they're split on the decision
why am i having to wear my mask
ccsd kindergarten teacher kristen nigro
has gotten the covet 19 vaccine and says
the school district's decision to keep
its mass requirement is ridiculous if
cdc comes out and says that we don't
need them anymore i'm kind of
disappointed
that i'm in as still as a vaccinated
adult and a fully vaccinated adult
i'm going to have to still wear them
she's especially concerned for her
students education since a large part of
the curriculum focuses on phonics the
kids actually have to see like the
mouth formation of how the lips are
forming it's just an
extra level of protection high school
teacher rhymed from all sides with ccsd
saying it's better to be safe than sorry
i know some parents
won't let their kids get to that seam so
i feel like benefit of having a mass
still
will allow them to make sure that if
they're if the
virus is in the skulls that they'll
still be safe
that's how some parents feel too i agree
100
for the kids still wearing the mask
because it's going to protect my child
but other parents say although safety is
the priority they feel the risk for kids
is low
i would hope that the school district
would start to
take into account some of the science
behind it
of the benefits of them not wearing
masks
ccsd says they'll give more information
about their policy
based on any new guidance local guidance
next week
reporting live from ccsd headquarters
tonight orca mana 8 news now